O ne o
[Müzik]
abone ol
Evet hepinize Merhaba burada olmak
gerçekten bir işim büyük yoludur ve size
İtalya'dan kucak dolusu sevgiler
getirdim
ve bugün buraya aslında sizinle yüzer
samimi sıcak bir sohbet etmeye geldim ve
sohbetine hayatımda küçük bir kesip
aktararak bahsetmek istiyorum
ya
ben de olmadan önce ayda benim ismimi
Aslında Ezgi olmadığımız
fakat Ben doğduğumda
birden bire görmeye geldi olduğunu
öğrenmişler ve dolayısıyla hep sesimiz
hem de çok üzmüşler Çünkü bu annemi
hamile gününde hiç böyle bir şey belli
değiliz
Ve tabii ki doğal olarak Annem kendini
Ağlamakta Avrupa'ya Biz ve annem her
alışa Benim de yakından yazarsınız
diyormuş bu ve bir Aha falan demiş
kendine
engel bizlerin ismini Ezgi koymaktan
satın are koyuyorum ki sonra da gibi
çalsın ben de buradan size Pınar çağırıp
olarak sizi selamlıyorum hepinize Hoş
geldiniz demek istiyorum
işte o
çok sıkı ismimizi seçebileceğiniz gibi
para verdiniz gibi
hayatımızda aslında bir de bizim karar
vereceğiz durumlarda vardır mesela hangi
Ailelerimiz yalnız hangi dil yetiremez
ip olacağımız göz rengini saç renginde
ve hayat Bunun yanı sıra bize bir sürü
sürpriz hazırlar Aslında Hani derler ya
hayatı Bizler adım diye İşte o bu Tam da
bu olsa gerek
bu ve buzun Biz de aslında bizim için
birer sınavdır
bazılarınız bunları bir video olarak
gibi hayatı dolu dolu yaşarız fakat
bazıları mıza bir felaket bir zulüm
olarak yürü hayatını zindana çevireceğiz
işte Tam da 24kasım
1999 günü hayat bu sürprizlerden birine
bana ve aileme yaptı Neydi bu sürpriz
verin
anahtarlı hastası olarak dünyaya
gözlerini açma
Alper masası Aslı kısaca tanımlamak
gerekirse bu doğumsal bir hastalık olup
ciddi sevildi ve görme sıkılan çok ne
yapıyorlar bir hastalık ve ben
2999 yılında o zaman atıp ve
teknolojisine dayanarak dünya
literatürüne geçen düşüncem sayfası
olarak doğdum
bu peki sizce daha hastalığı nasıl
gördüm 120 olarak gibi felaket olarak bu
Hayır asla ben bu hastalığı hayatının
bozulmuş olduğu bir armağan olarak
gördüm ve dedim ki Pınar bu artık senin
ayrılmaz bir parça bunu problem engez ve
bu da olduğunu hayatı dolu dolu yaşamak
gerek ve her zaman benim de yatacağım bu
olmuştu ve İnanın ki hayatta Aslında
hepimiz birer yıldız olarak doğruyoruz
ve doğduk
Önemli olan bu yıldızı nasıl
patlatacağız bilmek
nasılki yıldızlar
bu sağlamak için aşılamak için gücü
ayran alıyorsa
Bizlerde güçlüdür uçuşlarınızda
umutlarımıza hayattaki başarılarınız lav
E az Deniz ve isteklerinize kendi
yıldızımızı içinizdeki Yıldızı parlak
malıyız ki hayatınızda rengarenk ışıl
ışıl olsun bir küfürlü bir proje Misali
mi Evet
mm
Dünyası fiziksel görünüşün gibi
kapkaranlık mıdır Hayır tabii ki de mi
Evet ben görmüyor olabilirim Evet hiç
görmüyorum ışığın bölgenizde yüz
görmüyorum saat dünya tam tersine Işıl
ışığa yapar Cup Ayrılık
Tabii bu demek değildir ki benim
hayatımda hiç benim hayatım tamamen
güzelliklerle Mutluluklarla dolu Tabii
ki de hayatım da tıpkı hepimizin olduğu
gibi benim de karanlık noktalar var
zaten bu karanlık Doktorlar olmasa neye
yarar mutlu anlar güzel anlar ki
soğanlar var ama böyle o an bu karanlık
noktaları bir basamak olarak kullanıp ve
bir pusula olarak görüp
yönümüzü ardından çevirmek Önemli olan
bu yazısında hayatta
Allah hepinizin de bildiği gibi hayat
herkes için aslında bir mücadele
ve bu Akıp Gider suyu Akıp Gider zaman
yolculuğundaki bir sihir ve Aslında
hayat ve
biz hayatta
birçok engelle karşılaşıyoruz ve bu
engellerin Neredesin farklı ama benim
için hayattaki bu ilerler şu zaman öp
üründen kaynaklı
oy veren hep ben doğduğumdan beri Yani
kendini bildirdiğini hepsini uyandım
Evet Engeller Var ama bu engeller
kesinlikle aşılanması değilim tabii ki
bu engelleri oturduğumuz yardımlaşma
isteyerek bunu da biliyorum her zaman
çabaladım
bu gayret ettim Evet zorlandım
Ah ah hep inandım ki bu engelleri
aşabilmek için kendi kontroldan çıktı
olayım ve daima kendime inanmalıyım ve
güvenmeliyim ve her zaman da şunu
bildiğin değil Pınar bu hayat senin
hayatın Sen bu hayata bir kere
biliyorsun O yüzden engeller hiçbir
zaman seni Yıldırım'ı bunu
bu ve hep bu aksesi ya bu felsefeyle
yoluna rahmetinden hayatta
Ben 6 yaşına
geldiğinde artık ilkokul çağı
bu ve
bizden var mı yoksa doğdu ama
Marmaris'te herhangi bir görme görme
engelli yapılıyordu ve ailem de beni hep
bir ani görme engellilerle okumam için
bir olay arttıracaktır Dolayısıyla
varması olan en yakın il olan İzmir'e
taşını panama'daki görmeye geldim buna
yazdı daire
bugün buradayız severim şimdi mücadele
başlamıştı yani Düşünecek olursanız
Aslında altı yaşındaki bir çocuk için
hayat lay lay lay olur ama benim için
öyle olmadı benim için çok daha mücadele
başlamış bu hayatta tarafından çok
mutluydum
bu ve
ya Oha kayboldum ama size şu kadarını
söyleyebilirim ki Ben okula gittiğim
günden beri ilk günden Benimki daha
okula kendimi okul artist artist etmedim
Neden Çünkü
ben her zaman Şurayı yandı Evet ben
gördüm geldiğim ama toplumdaki diğer
insanlardan hiçbir farkı yok Evet sadece
bir bölüme geçtik ve Botanik de kabul
ediyorum ve bundan hiçbir zaman boyun
adım
ya Ama ben bu ellerinden dolayı Hiçbir
zaman kendimi toplumdan sorgulamadım
toplumdan kıskandım dolayı dedim ki
hayır ben de diğer insanlarla birlikte
aynı şartlarda eşit şartlarda eğitim
olabilirim Neyse ki Dört yılın sonunda
öğretmenim de bunu benim bu düşüncenin
fark edebildi ailemden habersiz
C1 numara Kula konuşuyor Beni bir aylık
bir deneme sürecini aldığını ve bu
deneme süreci gayet başarılı geçti ve
ben 5. sınıfta itibaren dolayı bir okula
gitmeye başladım Evet ayran saçlarını
Ama kabul etti
bu maalesef normal okula gittiğini
gideceğim zaman kayıt aşamaları çok zor
geçti benim okula kabul etmek isterim
Neden Çünkü Pınar görmüyor ve dediler ki
Yani bunların kendi okulları var Kendi
okullarında eğitim almak zorunda o
yüzden biz bunu kabul ederiz ve şunu da
altını çizmek istiyorum Bu hap yasal bir
hak olduğu halde hala ben onu demiyorum
Ölüme Bir sürü zorluklar bir sürü Kay
satılıyor ha ben ben burada en büyük
destek çift ailem olmakla birlikte biz
bu yolculukta Test ettik ve yıllık ve
biri En sonunda bu okula kaydettiler
mı ettin ama
bu çık Tamam kabul ettiler şimdi dört
tane öğretmenleri Deniz etmek zorunda
sınıf sınıflarına kabul edilebilecek ve
Şişli seviyor ve özellikle bir tanesi
diyor ki asla öyle demem Çünkü Pınar
görmediğim için değil çocukların
psikolojisini bozar
ya o yüzden bu var Tamam o zaman tarihe
tarih soğuk kura çekiliyor ve bir tanem
efsane diyor yani Ben çok şansızım
kesinlikle bana çıkacak böyle oluyor o
çıktı bu ve
ya ben bu ve başladım evin herkes seni
herkese Can ama ben de öyle yaptım bunu
belli etmiyorum gayet güçlü gayet soğuk
yatağımda derslere elinden gelen gayreti
gösteriyorum ve Neyse ki 15 yıl sonra
öğretmenannem işareti videonun
gelirsiniz diyor ki ben
kendimden utanıyorum bu sözleri sarf
ettiği bu düşüncelere Kapıldım için
Aslında çok yanlış yapmışım ve Sizden
özür diliyorum
ya Neyse ki 5 sınıfın sonunda
Benz yüksek doğru ortalamayla 5.
sınıfların birisi olarak seçiyorum ve
dört yıl yer8 sınıfa kadar bu okulla
ilgili devam ediyorum sonraki başarılı
nasıl başarılı oldum Benim her zaman
değildir her zaman hayatta evleri olurdu
büyüklü küçüklü Ve ben hep şuna inandım
Evet bu hayat benim hayatım hedefler
bilimi desin önümüze Tabii ki engeller
çıkacak Ama bu engeller bizi hayatta
vazgeçirmek yere tam tersine daha da
güçlendirecek
bu ve
38 sınıfta ise sınavlarına gireceğim
ilgili doğraması kazandım ve herkes dedi
ki yani Hayır olamaz kesinlikle
sorularda torpil var bu evliliğe Bu
mümkün değil dediler Benimki geldi az
olan konuşuruz maalesef İnsanların ağzı
torba değil ki büzesin iz Kulaklığımı
kapattım denilen laflara
ne yaptın
da benim en büyük hedeflerinden bir
tanesi de çocukluktan beri yabancı
diyorum özellikle İngilizce öğrenmek
Çünkü ben inanıyorum ki bir dil bir
insan
verdiği üç yaşından beri üzerinde
İngilizce konuşmaya başladı meve
eklerden sayılardan küçük küçük olmaya
başladım ve yakaladığım her fırsatı
değerlendirmeye çalıştım
yararlanabildiği Her kaynaklar kaynaktan
yararlanmayı da çalıştım
bu ve Anne hep derdim ki Ortaokulda
beğen liderin En azından bir böyle yurt
dışında ve Aslında Amerika'da okumak
istiyorum ve ailemin bunu her gördüğümde
kulağa bu imkansız bu olmaz mı oldu ama
ben de üzülüyorum Aslında onlar da hep
imkansız dedikçe ver et olsun daha fazla
çalışmaya başladım Daha da gayet ettim
ve İşte hayat bu olsa gerek 11 sınıfta
bana bir fırsat her bir fırsat çıktı Bir
vuruş bir Değişim Programı Amerika'da
bir yıl okuma ve ben hiç düşünmeden evet
dedim ve bu ailemi söyledim büyük bir
sessizlik sonra onlar da veri
desteklediler
Bu bir fakat dedim ki bir bunu
etrafımızdaki sana söyleyeceğiz
akrabalarında uzun Söylemediği tüm
işlemler olduğu hücreler çıktı artık
Pınar Wifi'ye gitmeye hazır ve bunu
söylüyor zaten Bilgilerinize
bu I'm ilk önce kendi babasıydı üzere
ara söyledi dedi Pınar Avrupa'ya gidiyor
ve derenin ilk dediyse Ben orada tek
çocuğu Siz bir tane çocuğa bakmadınız mı
gördük dedik yani Tamam sen öyle
düşünebilirsin
sonsuza düşünüyoruz
etrafında kulak kapayıp Amerika'ya
gittiği hazırdım
marka ayran belli oldu Texas edecektim
okulun belli oldu ve benim uçak bileti
bu herşeyi hızı Oh gecesi bir model
geldi teksas'taki okul sizi gördüğünüz
den dolayı kabul etmedi her şey değişti
ve şu anda gideceğiz eyalet güneykaravan
ama yediğinizde muhteşem bir hayatı
kırıklığı ve dinlediğim en gözyaşı
ama asla benden vazgeçmeyin eşin değilim
dedim ki Pınar bal geçelim ise bu kadar
Evet bu kadar çalım boşuna var Hayır
boşuna olmalı asla bütün olmamalı Çünkü
bilim heyetinde bu yıllardır kendimi
belirlediğim koyduğum hediyesi ve daha
koyabilirim ve sağlam yazdım
vazgeçmedim Aslında Uçağa bindim
gidiyorum
gitti Amerika'ya vardım
bu ve bir Dediler ki bana
ben size engellediğiniz Anladım posta
ile bulmak çok zor oldu O yüzden hafta
içleri Yatılı okulda kalacaksınız hafta
sonları hali yapacaksınız
5-10 saniye bir şey demedim çünkü Benim
Çocukluktan beri Yapı okul fobisi vardı
ve daha formülünü aslı şu anda karşı
tavsiye aldım
17. Yani ben sana ne yapmalıyım açıkçası
bilmiyorum
de kabul ettim ya Oğlum çok
yapabileceğim hiçbir şey yok tuşu neden
fobilerin için yazıyı oku ve Okulu her
bir eğitim kurumu olarak görün hiçbir
zaman bir konaklama yeri olarak gördüm
ve bu âlemden ayrılmadım O yüzden de hep
mutlu ol ve geçirip Anne geldi
bu Amerika'da ilk günün yatılı Okulu
niye uyudun eleyerek yedim Ne oluştu hep
yaptığım şey yatağın üzerinde oturup
alma
var yani 350 şanslı anlatırken bile daha
dün gibi hatırlıyorum Her zaman da
unutmayacağım
ama şu anda diyorum ki iyi hobiler
yüzleştim bu hobi gelmiştir Çünkü Yatılı
okulda kalmak bir çok daha güçlü
ayaklarının üzerinde çok daha sağlam
bakabilen bir Pınar yaptı ben yapımı
okulda Çünkü tek başına öğrendim hayatı
Çünkü bunun öncesinde aile vardı yanında
kararlarında
o dil nasıl hareket etmem gerektiğini de
ailem vardı ama Amerika'da ve Yatılı
okulda bunu bütün hayatını verme diyorum
hayatımın merkezine ben vardım aslında
evet birinci Amerika yepyeni bir
sayfaydı çok zor bir süreçti Ama şu an
böyle bakıyorum ki iyi ki de yapmışım
İyi idare Köye gitmiştim ve denizden şu
anda bu kadar iyice koşabiliyorsan bunu
Amerika'da
kaldım doluyum
O da
Ama bu Amerika programı bitti Döndüm
Türkiye'ye
En çokta olgunlaşmış çok daha sen olmuş
hayatta
kararınıza yönetilebilen yapılar ve
bizlerin iki amacım vardı dedim ki ben
daha sırlarını ne kadar genişletebilirim
ve bu öğrendiğim İngilizceyi Daha ne
kadar müşteri
taşıyabilirim beni eğitim ve yurt
dışında devam etmeliyim dedim ve
akademik yılının başlaması tarifi birer
kalmıştı
çok kısa bir araştırma sıcaklığı
çıktıktan sonra
bir ilk bitti eden bitkilerdendir kanal
oldu veren bir sonra kanalı larda
o lise eğitiminin kanala tamamladım ve
iki yıllık ön lisans eğitimi aldım
kanalında
da gitti karılara
mi Evet Elif'in anlamında çok güzeldi
kültürel ve dinsel çeşitliliğin oldu
Bugünkü olduğu için bir usmu çok gelişti
Çünkü ben inanıyorum ki her yeri kültür
her yerindeki bizim bakış açımızı çok
daha fazla zenginleştirir
bu ve
din Kanada aslında gelecek hedefini önce
oldu ve benim en çok bakış açımıza
zenginleştirdiği etkenlerden Bir de
kanalın bana İtalyanca ilgili birine
uyandırdığı meraklı futbol oldu
Ama ben bunu gereği
kim İtalya'da ders aldım kanalı da dedi
öğretmenimiz vardı A bu arada
italyancaya İtalyan kültürünün sonra
zaten ayrı bilgi var Ama dini hakkında
çok fikrim yok aslında
oh oh ve temiz gün sınıfa girdiğinde
boncuğunu değil İlerideki Evet Pınar
seyin sıradaki öğreneceği İtalyanca
olmalı
bu ne bulduğumuzda başladım
çalışmalarımı araştırmalarım dedim ki
ben artık kanalı devam etmeyeceğim şu
Çünkü bir Marmaris'te olarak yani çok
sıcak iklim Akdeniz iklimi ve Kanada'ya
gittim -42 derece
buzkar her yerde yok yani benim orucu
bozuyor daha fazla dayanamayacağım bu
soğuğa ve çok uzak aile Özenir manevi
duygular eşsiz Ben artık bir Akdeniz
ülkesinde üniversiteye gitme Devam
etmeliyiz dedim
bu ve 4 Türkiye'ye her İtalyanca
İtalyanca yeterlik belgemi aldım
araştırmaları sonucu başında yaptım ve
euro spor forms Of ya da bir aldım ve şu
anda
İtalya'da
üniversite eğitimime devam etmekteyim bu
tarafı ilişkiler üzerine
o evde Bu karar
Ya aslında ben bu kararı çok da Aileme
sormadan aldım Çünkü tüm İtalyan
oturuyorum kanalı ya gittiğimde aklımda
ama onlarla paylaştım ve bu kadar şanslı
şanslıydım ki değil aile aldığı her
karar da benim arkamda aydı ve beni
destekledi bunu hiçbir zaman sunar şunu
yap şöyle Olsun birisi zaman
yönlendirirler Çünkü onlar bana
inanmışlar ve güven işlerdeki Ben kendim
için düşünüp taşınıp ölçüsü artık en iyi
kararı alıp Bu doğrultuda bir karar
veririm Evet Eylül ayında 21 21 Eylül
ayında İtalya ya gitti başladım ve tabii
ki korkularım vardı nelerle
karşılaşacağım yine evliliğinden dolayı
sıkıntılar çıkacaksın diye
bu dans Biraz önce dediğim gibi şanslı
bir insandım insan onu
İtalyanca gerek değil Ece gerek
İtalyanca balık ürünleri sana
öğretmenleri hep çok iyi çok tatlı
insanlar ve bu yardımsever insanlar
çıktı bu ve benim hayatımda Aslında
doğru duruyorlar insanlar işte bunlardan
bir yere bir yere benim aslında
İtalya'da yorum kesişti Yolumuz adında
bir hocam da tanıştım ve o benim
hayatıma farklı dokunuşlar
İtalyanca öğrenmem de çok büyük bir
ilham kaynağı ve benim bir daha bir
görebileceğim bir engelli Sadece küçük
bir ters parçasına çevirip bana Aslında
Bunu hiçbir engel olmadığını fark
ettirdi ve benim için aslında şu anda
bir video haline geldi Bu yolu sayesinde
İtalyan dili öğrenmek asla bir vurgunluk
değil Tamamen bir zevk meselesi oldu
hayatımızda Evet biz hayata yalnız
geliyoruz yalnız ve yalnız soğuk Yalnız
büyük yalnız ölür örüyoruz öleceğiz a
ama bazen hayatımıza
çok dokunan insanlar bizi ilave insanlar
olması gerçekten bizim hayatımızda fark
yaratıyor hayatımızı gerçekler ve
ilgilendiriyor
bir de şunu söylemek istiyorum Evet
olumsuzluklar Aslında hepimizin için
zorluk değil bazen de bize güldürüyor
nedaben bir görmeye geldi olarak çok
fazla anlayışı gelişiyorum Örnek vermek
gerekirse bir hava limanının dayım
İslam'da hizmet seyahat ediyoruz uçağa
doğru yürümekteyiz bir tane çocuk yani
böyle bip bip ruhumu görünce vermemiz
Dün Süper bu süper güçlere kendinden çok
farklı insan olarak görüyor Ve ama böyle
Altı yaşından 6-7 yaşlarına küçük bir
çocuk annesi bir işim var Ah haline
ablaya bak Hem yürüyor hem uyum hem de
konuşuyor
dedi Yani
[Müzik]
bu
engelleri bundan Tabiki Çünkü bu
Ben 10 kendini Zafer Kolay değil mi Ben
öyle görünmeyen Bunlar çok doğal şeyler
Çünkü maalesef bir engeller yeterince
topluma kazandırdığı kazanamıyoruz bunda
ailelerine seti var
var ama benim ailem de mi eğlendiği
hiçbir zaman toplumdan soyutlanan
Özellikle annem nerede sosyal bir
Aktivite var nerede kültürel yaptırdı
var her zaman biri de kalktı her zaman
toplumda 2 şişe olmalı sağladı Bu yüzden
benim bu konudaki bakış açın çok daha
geniş çok daha
yavaş çok daha başkalarının gözünden
bunu görebiliyorum Aslında öyleyim ve
bir diğer anında
Bu otobüs değil bugün izmir-marmaris
arası seyahat ediyoruz ve ben burayı
arkadaşlar biliyorsunuz görmeye geldi
kulağıma
oluyorum öpüyorum otobüste arkanızda bir
yaşlı teyze annem yanımda Benimki
sürekli bana bakıyor Allah Allah bu
beyaz sayfada çocukevine gezdirip
duruyor bomba sayfalı iki saattir en
sonunda Annem anda döküldü bakıyor
bakıyoruz sormaya utanıyor ama en
sonunda kadın dayanamadı dedi ki Ya
kızım çok pardon ama dedi bu çocuğun yer
iki saattir boş sayfalık ilgezdi
duyuyorum anlayan Bu ne yapıyor
[Müzik]
Annem de tabi bu durumu izah ettim
Hayır yani bu sormalı ve hiçbir tam
buğday gerek yok yani böyle bunun gibi
çok çeşitli farklı onlar yaşıyorum ben
de ve hayatta
konuşmamın başında Dediğim gibi
biz getiririz dünyanın diğer düz olarak
doğruyoruz geliyoruz Önemli olan bu
yıldızı nasıl bakacağım yine ve bu
Yıldızı su hiçbir zaman uzaklarda
kilometrelerce uzakta gökyüzünde aramaya
gerek yok ya da bizim hayatımıza
insanlar başkaları yön verecek diye
beklememiz gerekir Biz hayatımızda bir
izleyici olarak olmaktan ziyade daima
hayatımızın başrol oyuncusu serisi
yönetmeni olup bu ve Diamond Biz oldu
hayatımızı o şekilde yön vermeliyiz yani
içinizdeki ışığı
o gökyüzünde değil
Ya aslında tam da kendimizi aradım yani
yüreğimiz aramalıyım Çok teşekkür ederim
Dediğim söyleyeyim mi